what is life like I mean because you are
you working out are you gonna are you
singing is that your deal now I've been
seen in songwriting in naturalised I
kind of sang and danced my whole life
and so now being in Nashville I'm
friends in the songwriting circle and in
the performing circle and so I just kind
of trying it out and enjoying it who's
your inspiration who do you think is
doing it right because she seems a
little more edgy country and talked
about drinking and just being herself
and I like that style how often are you
guys getting asked you know what is
happening with the wedding what is
happening with this I mean this is what
is happening with and we're just
surprised it took he doesn't calm us to
do like a proposal when I don't see it
coming and it kind of make it our own
thing in relive that moment as just the
two of us cameras don't we have a
surprise for you today with drew love on
the line the stakes couldn't be higher
the new bachelor Canada you met him what
are your feelings bacon at all we did a
little bromance going there
I mean he's tall he's blond blue eyes
athletic wasn't that the light no I just
sat there in the middle of them and they
were just like bromance and I look at
text he was worried that some girls
wouldn't be there for the right reasons
and we said there will be some that
aren't there for the right that's just
part of it did you get the sense that
women have fought over him in the past
I mean when you play for the New York
Yankees I'm sure that's gonna happen